elle à Tsukiji fillmore famiiy un nouveau
cas sous sot de cerca pensando go
deleon donateur visuel kelly heffron
aprecio la gente Laura Lisette austin
aries putito zack snyder secrétaire Dean
Acosta boîte Sookie gravité idée
ventre de dinde lucchese sur Deborah dosac infraction
mrs.  Adachi phénoménal faire Chris Nolan a
dog's ass le petit ET de casa sparta
débat a non vuoi a posi vocation fue tu
padre de Caro todos aqui el murfi de feu
ok so hustle up hein Ross fan comment avez-vous
trouvé l'idée originale de ce
scénario votre  les films prouvent votre amour
pour les arts visuels et bien Superman être produit
de la même manière que je savais que j'avais une chanson et
moi et j'avais cette idée que vous savez
peut-être que la musique pourrait être ce pont vers
un autre monde peut-être quand la musique vous allume
dans votre  tête la musique
vous emmène en fait dans un autre monde et quand
la musique s'arrête le monde s'arrête donc
c'était l'esprit qui était comme cette chaîne
que j'avais et puis le
reste a été construit en plus de ça je
veux vraiment faire Superman  se sentir plus réel, je
suppose, comme une façon étrange de dire et donc
vous savez qu'il y aura probablement plus d'
emplacements et plus de réalité moins stylisée, le
cœur léger que vous avez commencé avec un remake
ou une adaptation est-ce une vraie satisfaction
d'avoir votre propre original  scénario et
que pensez-vous de tous ces
remakes et adaptations qui commencent à bien
ennuyer le public c'est une bonne
question je vous sais je pense que c'est
vous savez avoir votre propre script c'est cool
et c'est amusant vous savez c'est de
la seule chose dont nous avons parlé  ce qui
m'intéresse, c'est que vous savez que vous
pensez que lorsque vous créez votre propre script,
c'est comme oh c'est la chose la plus personnelle qui
soit et ça l'est mais c'est bizarre
parce que c'est ce que ça me fait vraiment
réaliser, c'est que je ressens la même chose
pour tous  les films
qui vont jusqu'à tous ces remakes, vous
savez qu'Hollywood est toujours à la recherche d'une
chose sûre et c'est difficile, alors ils
veulent juste prendre quelque chose sur l'
étagère, c'est plus facile de laisser murah après votre
excellent 300 avec presque seulement des hommes que vous
choisissez de  diriger un groupe de femmes dans le sac
vengeance était-ce la même expérience pour
vous d'ailleurs après Superman Man of
Steel y a-t-il une chance que vous dirigiez
Xerxes diriger les filles était génial
comparativement je ne sais pas si c'est là  C'est
une comparaison à faire, les gars sont tous en
sueur et un peu dégoûtants et les
filles sont géniales, donc il y a cette
partie que je les ai torturées dans le gymnase et je les ai
torturées sur le plateau et elles ont
résisté avec une grande résolution et l'ont fait  ils ont
fait un travail incroyable et
tout ce que je leur ai demandé, ils l'ont
parfaitement fait et de cette façon, je ne peux pas
du tout me plaindre, j'ai écrit le
scénario de Xerxes et pour ce qui est de
savoir si je le réalise ou non, je  Je ne
sais pas si je peux juste
choisir le moment ouais le gars Adami revient à
une série sur ma meilleure femme dans la plupart des pièces
près de l'enfant comment est votre collaboration
avec Christopher Nolan sur Superman comment
est-ce quand pourrions-nous voir le premier
image intéressante Chris et moi je me
suis pas mal amusé je
parle de Superman et chris a
été incroyablement généreux tu
veux vraiment vraiment que je fasse mon film mais
encore une fois il est là si j'ai une
idée ou quelque chose comme ça  Je déteste Chris, qu'est-ce que
tu en penses alors  c'est amusant, nous
ne commençons pas à tourner avant août, ce qui
est en fait assez tôt quand on y pense,
c'est presque avril, donc je
suppose que bientôt
un de plus comment Bay Door aimeriez-vous
créer votre propre série de bandes dessinées un jour
ou  avez-vous des projets, on m'a demandé
plusieurs fois de faire une série de bandes dessinées
ou une bande dessinée et
cela m'intéresserait, honnêtement, je n'ai tout simplement pas eu le temps
de mettre quelque chose en place, mais
oui, nous aimerions faire une bande dessinée  livre I a
new vejo donkeys x nada sobre todo en
avión to stay posi unit oh no sucker
punch Tatiana salutamus Pasha algues odometer
kino de foie gras
you